THE GOALS IN THAT ONE, AND IVAN.
THE COYOTES THEY KNOW THEY CAN
COYOTES.
THAT ONE RIGHT THERE TIME.
M ERRANT GOSTISBEHERE.
>> Tyson: JUST A LITTLE BIT OF A
NET.ME
OFFENSIVE ZONE.ONOK BACK UP FOR
NOT MUCH, BUT
RANTANEN JUST BANGS THAT ONE
HOME.
THAT PUCK SITTING RIGHT THERE OH
A GOAL.
>> Tyson: 49th POINT.DEVELOPED.
BURAKOVSKY A GOAL AS WELL.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT A LOT LAST S.
SO NOT MUCH OF A DIP.
THAT GETTING HIS
TOP TWO LINES OUT THERE EVERY
OPPORTUNITIEIE.
INSIDE THE OFFENSIVE BLUE LINE,
THIS T NET.
NICE INDIVCERTAINLY DOES, YOU
KNOW A LOT ABOUT
KUEMPER HIT A COUPLE OF BODIES
NOW, JOHNSON ON THE BACK-CHECK
JUST GETS ENOUGH.
UP.
AND TRACKED THE REBOUND
BY
THERE.
JUST DREW ON THE SCREEN.
THAT'S THE AREA YOU HAVE TO
DUMPED IN BYRY TONIGHT.
AND EVERY ONE OF THOSE TURNOVERS
IT SEEMS LIKENEDS UP IN THE BACK
OF THE